今日はこのアンリマーラ経典の最後でしょうと思います
アタコーアヤスマーアンリマーロラオーガトーパティサッリーノ
ヴィムッティスカーンパティサンヴェーディーターヤンウェーラーヤンイマンウダーナンウダーネーシ
えーまあ アタコー その時
アヤスマーアンリマーロ
アンリマーラ尊者が ラホーガトーパティサッリーノ
ラホーガトーっていうのは
一人でいるということで
パティサッリーノっていうのもおなじみなんですね
ラホーっていうのは  秘密という意味もありますけど
日本訳はどうなってるんでしょうかね
さて ソンジャングリマラススッカニ
毒させて  なんでしょう
どうしましょうか 一応まあ
その意味はそれで あの
よろしいと思いますけど
あのまあ 私の意味説明しますけど
ラホっていうのは  ラハスというね
言葉がね あります サンスクリット語で
いわゆる秘密っていうことなんですね
だから内緒っていうことかな
ですから  ラホーガトーっていうのは
もうそういう状態にガトーなりましたっていうことで
ですから 意味は その場合は
人々から離れていると
という意味で パティサッリーノっていうのは
パティサッリーナっていうのは
この どこかからこの下がって下がって
後ろに下がっている状態
パティサッリーナっていう状態なんです
ですから その場合は意味は
この 対象から  離れていったっていうことで
一人にいたっていうことなんです
だから このラホーガトーパティサッリーナっていうのは
いつでも  一緒に使うんです
それから ヴィムッティスカーンパティサンウェーディー
ヴィムッティスカーンっていうのは
自分が解脱を得たという
その楽しみを その喜びを
で こういうよろ  スカって言えば
本当にこの充実感じる味わう喜びスカなんですね
ただ あの 心で機嫌良くなったっていうぐらいのソーマナッサではないんです
心でちょっと機嫌がいいということは
ソーマナッサって言うんですね
スカといえば もう本当に具体的に感じる
この安らぎっていう意味なんです
で ヴィムッティ すぐ解脱という
その安らぎをパティサンウェーディー
感じながらっていう パティサン
感じて  ターヤンウェーラーヤンイマンウダーナンウダーネーシ
ターヤンウェーラーヤン
その時 イマンウダーナン
このウダーナンっていうのは
自然発生する言葉っていうことなんですね
ウダーネーシ  話しましたと
で 大変喜びを感じて 大変幸福感
至福感をもうあまりにも感じて
で これを こういう以下の偈を語りましたと
そちらにあるのは  自分で作った作品もあると思いますけど
ほとんどお釈迦様が  いろんなところで言った
教えた あの 言葉なんですね
それは自分ですごく楽しく喜んで
あの  歌ってるんですね
ヨーチャプンベーパマッジットワパッチャソーナップマッジャティー
ソーマンローカンパバーセーティーアッバームットーヴァチャンディマー
ソーイマンローカンパバーセーティーアッバームットーヴァチャンディマー
よー 誰かが プッベー  えっと
前 以前ですね パマッジットワ
かなり怠って怠けていて
パッチャ 後 後で ナッパマッジャティー
そう 怠ることはしないと
ソーイマンローカン そう
彼が イマンローカン この世界を
パバーセーティ 照らしたんだよと
どのように？アッバーハムットーヴァ
アッバーハっていうのは蜘蛛のことを
ムットー 蜘蛛から出てきた
チャンディマー いわゆる月のように
で 以前怠けていて 今怠けていない
それで世の中を照らすという
うーん  ここら辺 いくつか
法句経に ダンマパダに出てきますけども
ほとんど出てきます このプッピパマジットはパッチャソナッパマッジョティっていうのはどんな意味でしょうかね
で 以前怠っていて 今怠って
以前怠けていて 今怠けていない
まあそれだけで世の中照らすんだという
まあ北教の勉強会で説明しましたからね
する必要はないと思いますけど
このパマッジットっていうことには
この二つの場所で二つの意味がありますけど
で これはダンパダに聞かなかった方々もいますので
このパマーダという言葉から出てくると思います
えーと パマーダっていうのは怠ることなんですね
で 怠ることっていうのは
まあもう残念なことにこの怠るという意味ではなくて
この仏教の専門用語になりまして
あのまあこれ仏教で特別な意味で使っているんです
で 一般的には辞書でただ怠けているという意味なんですけど
まあその意味で解釈するのは普通なんですけど
でも仏教ではその意味で解釈をすると
それは間違っちゃうんですね
なぜならば それは仏教の特別な専門用語なんです
で この俗世間で まあ普通に生きることは
まあ怠って生きていること
生きていることやと言うんです
智慧を開発しないで 鈍感地の感情のままで生きている
その生き方がこのパマードというんですね
で これマッツというこの言葉もありまして
マッドインメイディという風な動詞ですけどね
で 酔うという混乱する酔うという動詞なんですね
だから酔ってる状態で
で マッジャといえばまあ本当にまあ酔ってるという
で 五戒という戒律があります
そちらにはマッジャパマーダッターナという言葉がありますね
そちらもマッジャっていうのは酒に関係あるものだから
酔うことなんですね で
酔うマッジャパマード
酔ってパマーダになる
だから同じ言葉なんですね
で 酔ってる状態で酔ってる状態っていうのは
やっぱりこの 何でしょうかね
まあ怒りてる状態なんですね
何かに で 人々っていうのは普通には
例えば欲が生まれてると
欲のエネルギーで 欲の衝動で欲に生かしてるんですね
あるいは怒りが出てくると
もう怒りで人を生かしてるんですね
だから 人々がやってる行動っていうのは
知識的に考えて判断してやってる行動ではなくて
心の感情でもう考えさせたりする
感・感情 行動させたりする
だからすごいしつこくいろんなことを考えていても
ほとんどそれはもう理屈に論理にならないんですね
ただ 自分が何か感情でこれが正しいと思っちゃうと
その思ったことがなぜ正しいかと強引に理屈つけるんです
で 世の中にある論理はそういう論理なんですね
で 何を見てもみんなこの自分が決めたものに強引に論理つけている
で 誰かが悪いと言って気に入らなかったら
その人のかすかな悪いことでもかなり巨大化してしゃべるんですね
この間テレビで聞いたんですけど
このまああの首相の給料を横取りすることについて
あの自民党やら共産党やら立憲社会党いろいろ党の人々は集めていて
そこで国民裏切ってとんでもないことをしているのは共産党だと言って
自民党の人々はものすごく怒鳴りつけるんですね
あんた方はよくもそんなことをやっているのではないかと
その場合の理屈は この共産党はこのちゃんと約束させて
あのあんた方の給料のこれぐらい何パーセントぐらい払いなさいと約束があったみたいですね
ですから  それは国民を裏切ったんだということで
だから どういうふうに裏切るって
これは説明はないんですけどね
で それでみんななるほど
そういうことやということで
で 喋れ喋れなく 話させ話させなかったんですね
共産党の人々に で 裁判かけて訴えているということで
だからその場合はちゃんと約束あって報告しているんだから
あの国会でなんとかうんぬんとはできないんですね
国会でできない 合法的にやっても
嫌な人だったら悪いとで
好きな人だったら まあ合法的違法的にやっても何とか許してあげましょうとという理屈なんですね
だからそれが世界でどこにでもある
あの論理なんですね だから正しい誰が正しい
誰が正しくないかを決める場合は
まあ誰のことを好きか
誰のことを嫌いかということで決めるんですよ
で 裁判になってきたっても同じことで
裁判官に気に入られると
まあすごい優しい判決を下すし
気に入らなくなっちゃうとかなり恐ろしい判決を出すんです
ですから このそれが合法的で正しいということになっているんです
裁判官に気に入らなかったと
で ちょっと失礼ではないかと思ったとかね
で そういうことだけで十分ですよ
厳しい罰を受けるためには
で 合法的です 裁判官を侮辱しましたと
裁判所をけなしたっていうね
それでまあ 好き勝手に
好き勝手ではないんですけど
合法的にその人を罰せられるんです
で 気に入ったならば あの
まあ問題はないんです
私はもう見ていたところで
例えば裁判 審判をやっている時は声でも出したら大変なことになります
でも 裁判官が知っている人々なんか平気で喋ったり
平気で声出したりいろいろしますけど
それはもう知らない 見てないということにするんですね
自分がもう知ってない人やら
初めて参加している人やらに
ちょっとでもしきたり知らなくて何か間違いを起こす
それはものすごい厳しいその場での 1日
じゃあ 1日中あんたも鍵かけておいて入れるというね
そういうこともするんですよ
だからそれがまあ裁判官が決めるんですよ
侮辱したかないかということは
だから誰でも喋ったら侮辱ということになるわけじゃないんです
その場合でも 裁判官が認めているかないかという
気に入っているかないかということで
で まあそういうことですから
俗世間の場合は正しいか正しくないかという判断というのは
まあ自分の好みか あるいは自分気に入ってないかという
で だから自分好き だから好きか嫌いには理屈はまずない
それ感情ですからね 好きか嫌いかということには理屈はない
それはもう全くの感情
例えばアル中になる人やらね
麻薬中毒になる人やら
いろんなゲーム中毒になる人やらね
いろんなものに中毒になったりする
その人はそれが好きなんですね
理屈で好きになっているわけじゃないんです
ただ あまりにも好きだからやめられない
理屈で時間これぐらいなくなるんだぞとかね
お金がこれぐらいなくなるんだ
なくなりますよとかね
健康はこういうふうに
こういうふうに悪くなるんだぞとか
そういう理屈は成り立たないんですよ
ですから 例えば何かに中毒になる人は
決して理屈ではなくて
それ感情 それで理屈というのは
その感情を正当化するために強引につけるものなんです
ですから 人がペラペラ理屈しゃべってるんだからといって論理的ということにはなれないんですよ
論理的になるのは 全くも感情なく
全くもクールで淡々と語るときなんですね
だから好みというものはまるっきり使わない
全くの機械的に客観的に判断すると
論理になるんです でも
そうなるかということは大変な難しいことなんですね
判断という一言葉自体でも
もうほとんど好みで判断するんですから
判断にはならないんですね
感情はもうとっくに判断しているんです
だから この作った判断に何とかレポートを書きましょうということは
理屈なんですね そういうことで
この世の中のすべての生命というのは
貪瞋痴のこの感情の衝動で生きている
学問も研究も論理も政治も経済も何から何まで教育ももうこの衝動でやっているんですね
そういう生き方では 客観的な事実発見というのはもう成り立たない
ありえないんです ですから
この真理発見するために
もう哲学勉強しても 経済学勉強したっても
社会学勉強したっても発見はできません
例えばこの社会学ということがありまして
民衆学とかいろいろありますよ
で まあ日本でもやっていると思いますけど
いろいろいろんな文化とか勉強したりするんですね
それは学問的な研究やというんですけど
やっぱりほとんど西洋で研究してますけど
そちらその西洋から他のどこかの民族のところに入り込んで
その人々と一緒に生活して
もう厳密にデータ取って研究すると
そういう場合でも ただ主観であって
それで人間の生き方を発見できるということはできないんですよ
だから 自分たちには最初からある判断があるんです
その判断で正しいかないかということに決めるんですね
それでさらに学術的に威張って
そう 何かの文化を間違っているんだと判断してはいけませんということで
ただデータだけ出して判断しないでおくとかね
それで威張ったりする
それも同じことなんですね
で 結局事実出してくれるわけじゃない
データがそれなりにカテゴライズしているんだからね
で 悪いと言わないで まあまあ
これとこれとこれとこれとこれとこれとどんどんどんどん比較していく
それで読む人はもうきちんと判断してしまっちゃうんですね
その論文を読む人は 結局その判断に書いた人が
もう読む人をその判断するようにも
何て言いますか 仕掛けられているんですよ
だから文書上判断ないと言ったってもね
そうはならないんです
ですから難しいということなんですよ
人間というのは貪瞋痴で生きているということは
事実であるならば もう正しい論理的な生き方が出てくるということは出てこない
あり得ない それで貪瞋痴っていうのは感情であって論理ではありませんし
理屈は全くもない 好きなものは好き
嫌なものは嫌というぐらいのことで終わっちゃうんです
だからそうやって好きやと嫌やと決めるのも無知だからなんです
ものの本当の状態がわからないんだからなんです
ですから 好きだったら万人がそれ好きでなければいけません
すべての生命がそれ好きと言わなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば何か 30センチだよと言ったら
長さはそれはどんな人間測ってみても 30センチなんですね
長さはもう変わらないはずなんですね
事実っていうのはそういうもので
地球は丸いというと これは誰にしたっても丸いんですよ
ミミズにしたっても地球は丸いんです
知っているかいないかということは関係ないんです
だから誰かが知っているかいないか
これは別そうな個人的な話で
事実は事実なんです それで個人が決めたものが事実であるならば
すべての生命にそれは事実なんです
だから個人個人が何か判断すると
その判断自体が普遍的な真理でなければいけませんよ
ではミミズに地球は丸いと発見することはできますかというと
それはできないんですね
では我々にできますかというと
私はできないと思います
地球は丸いと証拠を出すこと
で 私たちにはと言ったら失礼ですから
じゃあ私には地球は丸いということはちょっと証拠を出せません
自分で発見したわけじゃないので
みんな言ってるんだからそう言ってるんです
私も 地球は丸い丸いよと
自分で知ってるという自分では知りません
だから地球は丸いというのは
もう誰か誰かが発見して言ってることで
私にはその能力はない
知りません で 飛行機なんかに乗って下をずっと見ていたことはあるんですけど
やっぱり丸くは見えませんね
ですから それ以上は行ったことはないし
ですから やっぱり丸いですと丸かったとかいう感想はなかったんですね
今まで 話を聞くと なるほど丸いですかねという感想はありますよ
なるほど とかね また宇宙から撮った写真なんか見たら
なるほど丸いんだなとかということにはなるんですけど
それも最近出てくる画像でで見ると
でもそれが地球かどうかまたわからないんですね
それでこの個人 地球が丸いと言ったのも個人なんですよ
それで私は何言いたいかというと
個人が何かを判断すると
それが普遍的な客観的な真理かないかということなんですよ
判断したならば それが普遍的な客観的な真理でなければいけません
なぜならば でないと私は間違っている判断しているでしょうに
間違っている判断して間違っている行動するでしょうに
では問題は私には地球は丸いと自分で判断できるかと
これはまあ無理な話で
では個人には正しい判断できないんだから
じゃあまあいいんじゃないかと思っちゃう
どうなるんですかね みんな好き勝手なことを判断して
それが正しいと思って大変なことになってしまっちゃうんです
だから私がこの人が悪いと判断しても
大勢の人々はその人は悪くないと言っちゃうんですね
そこで それは私の個人的な判断で
他の人々の個人的な判断で
では事実は何なのかと
その人は何者かと 何か事実はあるはずなんですよ
Xさんが悪い人間だと私は言うと
また他の人は Xさんは良い人間やと言っちゃうと
一体全体 X さんは何者かと
それがあるんでしょうね
X さんについては事実は
それで じゃあ多数決で決めようって言った
それ正しいんですかね
それも当てにならないんですよ
で 私と 3人 X さんが悪いとする
で  80人良い人やという
故に X さんが正しいとは判断になりません
なぜならば 我々も何かの一部を見て言ってるんだから
ですから 真理を発見するために
多数決も当てにならないんですよ
で 大変な困ったことになります
しかし 人間は真理を知るべきなんです
それにはもう全員全会一致やと思いますよ
間違ったことを知りたくないと
間違ったことをやりたくないと
間違ったものは食べたくないと
というのは誰にも考え方なんです
間違った行動はしたくないんだと
間違った行動をしたくない
それは当たり前でしょう
誰かそちらの窓を開けて
そのまま道路に行こうとはしないでしょうに
もし誰かが間違った判断をして
これは一回だと 二回なのに
これは一回やと思って
では出かけますと帰りますと言って窓を開けて外へ出ると
それがその人の間違った判断ですよ
だから間違った判断は誰もしたくないんです
間違った判断はもう決して正しい結果出すわけじゃないんです
判断が間違ってるんだから
正しい判断で行動すると正しい結果を出す
ですから人は生命が真理を知るべき
事実を知るべき それには異論はないんです
それで真理を知る のは個人なんですね
結局は そこで お釈迦様の言葉から言うと
まあその各個人が貪瞋痴という感情で生きている
感情があるんだからこそ
全く論理性がもうない
感情には論理性はない
貪瞋痴には理屈はない
貪瞋痴正当化するために理屈はあるんだけど
そんなのは仏教から見ればすべて屁理屈なんですよ
まあ例えば あのイスラエルがパレスチナを今攻めて攻めることが正しいと
片っ端から潰した方がいいと
もうパレスチナ人にも二度と立ち上がらないようにするべきやと
なぜならば もうテロ活動をやっている
テロは根絶するべきと
で そちらでそういうふうに判断している
もう一応あの先進国々は一応一般的にはそういう判断している
でもイスラエルのやり方は間違っていると
またたくさん国々が思っている
力ないんだから言えないだけであって
もう多数決だったらもう間違ってるって方にはたくさん投票を得られると思いますけどね
で まあアメリカと日本ぐらいかな
あとイギリス で その三票しか得られないと思いますけど
でもそちらの方が一応正しいと通してますね
ではそれは理屈かというと
その理屈はこういうことなんですね
やっぱりパレスチナ人潰しちゃいましょうという
もう我々の仲間ではないかと
イスラエル人がっていうのは
そちらで好みが働いているんですね
で 好みが働くと それに理屈どんどんどんどんつけていく
自爆テロをうんやとかね
で ちょっと違った角度もあるんじゃないかと
この間総理に聞くという
もうテレビ放送がありまして
何さんでしたっけ？小沢さん
質問するんですね 総理に
すごく鋭い質問やと思う
ものすごく明確に分析して
で このイスラエルの攻撃について
パレスチナ人もその問題について
総理はどういうふうに考えているんですかということで
で 見事に小泉さんは日本語わからないみたいですね
それで もうなんとかすごい胸を張って答えるんですね
もうちゃんと調べて きちんと態度を取るべきです
なんとかとかね それで私はそういうことは聞いてないんだと
で そんなのは当たり前ですと
で 私が聞いたのは このパレスチナ人の行動はテロ活動か
あるいは自分の国民の普通の自由運動かと
どんなふうな定義していますかと
それ聞きたかったんですけど
どうかわからないみたいってことで
その人は次の質問に行ったんです
やっぱりわからないんですよ
定義できないんでしょうね
私もそれで あ なるほど
だからこれ定義だけのことやと
で パレスチナ人の自爆活動は
この自分の国民の解放運動
国を守るためのことになっちゃうと
これはもう普通に認める行動になっちゃうんですね
で それがもう関係ない一般人を殺すことやと判断しちゃうと
例えば殺された人々は一般人が一人二人でもいたら
一般人が殺したと 故にテロやとも定義できるし
ですから 結局は仏教の立場から見れば
テロって何なのかという定義はまだまだ成り立ってないんですよ
定義ないんですよ みんな好みに定義する
あのグループが嫌だったらもうテロだと
我々の仲間だったらテロではありませんと
同じ行動をしても ですから
例えば皆様方でもどちらに判断するかっていうことは
自分の心にある好みでいっちゃう
テロですよと だから堂々テロですしたって
私はそれは好みだよと
テロではないんですよと言ったら
私はそれも好みだよと
世の中で 俗世間ではそうやって決めることは何一つもできません
誰も定義を持ってないんです
だからそういうのはすごく難しいんですよ
[背景音楽]インドネシアで今
なんとか国が独立したんですね
あれ どの国？ティモール
で 東ティモールって独立しまして
それ独立運動をやっていた時は
ティモール人は何者かということ
また疑問になってくるんですね
インドネシアにはインドネシアの法律があって
憲法があって それを認め
それに対して反対運動をやっちゃうと
もう憲法違反でしょう
そうすると非国民で もう殺しちゃえばいいということになっちゃうんですね
それでインドネシアの軍隊が平気で捕まっては殺す
捕まっては殺すと それでインドネシアの政府側から見ると
もうテロで もう殺すべきということになってしまう
でもティモールはキリスト教の人々だから
西洋から見ればその人々は正しくて
殺されるのはよくないということで
やっぱり独立した方がいいということで働きかけて
独立することになってしまっちゃったんですね
だからとインドネシア人がすごい機嫌よく
はいはい どうぞ独立しなさいと言ったわけじゃないんですね
だからどちらの判断 これはどちらでも好みで判断する
まあ私にも判断があります
私はそれはそれは政府的なことよりも宗教的な汚い殺し合いだからね
それはけしからんと イスラム教はキリスト教を殺すことはとんでもないけしからんことやと
イスラム教もキリスト教もイスラムの人々を殺すことはとんでもないけしからんことやと
で ムスリムの教会とキリストの教会は隣り合わせであったっていいんじゃないかと
それぞれ自分がお祈りするところに行けばいいでしょうにという立場から見れば
私もやっぱりこれはけしからんことだというふうには決めてあったんですけど
いわゆるインドネシア政府やってることは
だったらその人々は独立させた方がいいんじゃないかと
独立したところで ティモールに住んでいるイスラム人がまた不公平になっちゃうんだったら
それまたけしからんことなんですね
でもそういう判断は世界は全然しないんですよ
だからその時も私にも一つの土台があるんですよ
人は誰でも生きる権利があるんだと
人は誰でも自分の好きな宗教を信仰する権利があるんだよ
それは奪うなよという自分の立場なんですね
では それが世界認めてるか
それは認めてないんですよ
あなたが間違っていると堂々と言うんです
そんな好き勝手に自分で宗教選んで信仰してる
それはダメですよという人はいくらでもいるんです
人はみんなにもう生きる権利があります
とんでもないことやと
悪い人はどうやっても生かしていればとんでもないことになるんだと
やっぱり悪を潰すべきですよという厳密に攻撃する人々はいるんです
そういういろいろ話したり
喧嘩したりすることも前はありましたけどね
ですから 判断というのはそういう
どちらが正しいかということはどうも言いにくい世界なんですね
そういうふうに この世の中ではみんなこの操られて引っ張られて
みんな言うこと ああそうですか
ああそうですか ああそうですかと生きているんだけど
一言うこと一つも ああそうですかと聞かないのは仏教は聞かない
ああそう で終わっちゃうんです
できないはずなんですよ
だからお釈迦様は判断するならば慈しみに基づきなさいと
そうすると やっぱり世の中で判断しなきゃ生きていられないんですよ
選挙になってきた 誰かにの名前を書いておかないと
判断しなくちゃいけないんですよ
それでどうやって判断するかというと
やっぱり慈しみに基づいて判断すればいいんですよ
今度 今度の選挙で誰の名前を書くかという場合は
その人々の中でよりたくさん人々のことを心配するするそうに感じられるのは誰でしょうかと
ふうに判断しなくちゃ判断することなんです
その場合は そんなにしがみついて
この人だったらもうとにかく当選してやるぞということでもなくなっちゃうんですね
まあ例えば このこのアンケート調査やっているところの情報を見ると
小泉さんを推薦する人も推薦しますか？総理として
って言ったら  40%以上は推薦します
理由は聞いたら もうたくさんの人々
他の人はいないんだからと
それが決して私はその判断はいいと思いますね
我々も誰でもろくな人ではありませんということで
その中で誰やってまあまあいいんじゃないかっていう
あんまりしがみすぎて
この人こそ救い 救済主者だよというふうな気持ちじゃないんですね
まあいいんじゃないかと
やっぱりすごく生ぬるい考え方かもしれませんだけど
やっぱりそういうことしかもう出てこないということでもあります
やっぱりそれよりもうちょっとしっかりと
全ての国民には幸福はもってこなくても
やっぱり首を数えてみて
この人はたくさんの人間に幸福をもたらすようにしてあげてるんではないかという風にでも決めなくちゃいかないね
その場合でも 決める基準はやっぱり慈しみになっちゃうんですね
だから 世の中で判断して生きていきたければ
慈しみで判断する 慈しみの中には貪瞋痴はまるっきりない
それは人が幸福になってほしいと
ただそれだけの気持ちですから
そちらには貪瞋痴はないんですね
それで私はずっと難しいことを言ったかもしれませんだけど
言いたかったのは この世の中であらゆる判断やら基準やらあるんだけど
全て一切全体 一つも当てにならない
ということなんです それ理解すると
ものすごく気楽になるんですよ
気が楽になるんです 人が何言ったっても
そんなにもう苛立ったり
神経質になったりはしません
逆にその人何言ってるかとかわかるんです
それで言っているところもわかるし
間違っているところも見えてくる
だから自分では判断しないんだけど
誰よりも頭が動くと そういう状態にはなります
ですから この普通世の中で生きている人々が貪瞋痴という感情でまず判断して
それからもうそれに理屈という何かレポートをつける
なぜこれでしょうかと
なぜってないんですよ
ただそれが好き これが嫌いだけのことなんです
それなぜがないんですよ
なのに なぜがついちゃうんですね
だから世の中でどんな論理にも反論が成り立ってしまうんです
全てのテーシスというものはアンティテーシスを持っているということはあって
それが仏教の思考の世界で明確に堂々と言っていることなんですね
テーシスというものはアンティテーシスを持っているんだと
論はいつでも反論 反論と一緒に飛び上がってくるんだと
だから飛び上がったってすぐ倒れるんです
このパマーダという生き方は
その生き方にパマーダと呼んで
その生き方で 100年
200年  300年ではなくて
1億年生きていたっても一つも発見しないでしょ
このパマーデの生き方で貪瞋痴でまず決めて
それからもう強引になせつける
自分の好みにしつけたんだから
他の人はそれはその通りだと思わない
そこで好きやとなせつけた
なせ 理屈つけたものも嫌になったところで
また何のことなく理屈つける
それで堂々とすごい知識的な人間だと胸を張って生きている
で 入れっていうのは 人と誰か一緒に生活していると
この人素晴らしい人やと
もう大好きやと なぜかと聞いたらいくらでも言うんですよ
私はこういうわけでこの人と一緒に生活しているんだよと
そこでその人を嫌になったら
なんで嫌になったんですか？こういうわけで
こういうわけで嫌になったんだ
で 平気で言う だから 何か出来事あって
突然性格変わったならば
まあいいんですけどね
私はこういう性格でありましたから
その人と仲良くしていたんだけど
あるこういう出来事を経て
で この人の性格が変わってしまったと
で 前の性格は今はありませんと
だから一緒にいられませんと
言うならばいくらか理屈なんですけどもね
そうでもないんですよ
だからそうやって一緒になっていて
また別れる人々から できればアンケート取って聞いてみてください
その人は本当に性格全く変わったんですかと
全く変わったわけじゃないんです
ただ単に嫌になったと
それだけのことで まあ理屈つけちゃう
だいたい世の中のそういう状況だから
そういう生き方だったら
いくら生きていても 何を発見しても
どんな研究をしても 真理というものの発見は無理
不可能ということなんです
ですから 俗世間の生き方はパマーデの生き方だよという
その意味ですね ただ怠っているんだというふうな単純な意味でもではないかもしれません
そういうアッパマーデ生き方というのはアッパマーデ生き方っていうのは
この瞬間瞬間 まるっきり主観を捨てて貪瞋痴を捨てて
ありのままに見てみようとする
全くの判断しないで その瞬間からその人をもう何も判断しない
ただ見ているだけで観察するだけで
ヴィパッサナーサティというのはその働きなんですね
大変な難しいかもしれませんですけど
そんなに難しいわけでもないんで
判断しなきゃいいということだから
でありのまま自分の体に触れる情報をチェックしてみる
その場合ははっきりと体に触れる情報にする
あるであろうと思う何かについて考えたりはしません
それが自分が思うことだから
自分の思考 自分の心の中にあるものであって
神様がいるだろうということは自分の思考であって
それでその思考という
そのそれだけ観察してみる
そうすると それは好みであって
期待であったということは見えてくる故に
もう客観的な事実という証拠ではありませんと
ただ これは好みであると
期待であると それでいろいろ感情
いろいろ感情も いろいろ気持ちも
あらゆるものこの体の中で生まれてくると
それだけ見ておくと こういうわけでこうがあって
これを事実かないかといえば
事実にはならないと 客観的な事実にならないと
だから この地球は丸いかないかというふうには探し求めてはいかないんですね
体に触れる情報のみをもう観察してチェックしてみると
見ると必ずも心の中で変革が
変革というか改革が起こすのです
その巨大な改革自体が悟りと呼ぶんですね
その人格的にいきなりとてつもないすごいこの改革が起こさない限りは悟ってないんです
で それにはこの客観的に物事を観察するという仕事をしなくちゃいけない
で 観察する生き方っていうのは
全く日常の俗世間の生き方とは全くも違う生き方なんです
でも 厳密に知恵の生き方で
本当に論理的な生き方で
もう厳密にもう心理的な生き方なんです
で そこでこの因果法則というものは
その仕事がすごい ものすごいたくさんにやっていると
因果法則というものは見えてくるし
それで初めてお釈迦様おっしゃったこの超越した発見
無常ということ 俗世間という無常ではありません
それが発見できて 心にとにかく改革を起こすんです
だから改革を起こした人がこの世の中でもう誰で誰よりもすべての生命よりも優れている智慧の人なんです
だってみんな貪瞋痴の中で好みに理屈つけてばっかり生きているんだから
それで今までパマーダでいた人が
後でいきなりパマーダやめてアッパマッジャティ
アッパマーダで生きてみると
それでその人は世の中は雲から出てくる月のように世の中照らすんだと
ですから こちらでこの普通の人が普通にみんなと怒り
怒りたい時は怒ったり
欲張りたいとか欲張ったり
それで怒りで判断したり
いろんなことをした人々はある日突然それ全てやめて
物事を観察してみようではないかと
判断やめましょうと いて
主観をやめて行動してみる
それはナッパマッジャティということ
パッチャーソーナッパマッジャティ
後彼が怠ることはしないと
それで精神改革が起こるんですね
この精神的なすごい改革によって貪瞋痴は綺麗さっぱり消えると
貪瞋痴消えた途端 感情が消えたところだから
もう論理的なんです 貪瞋痴がある限りは論理ではありません
合理も論理も何もないんですね
そこでこの芸をアンリマーラ大長老に合わせてみると
もう言われたままに生きてきたんですね
世の中で正しいということ
だから先生がこのもう神様に何でしたっけ？この
何かお供えをしなくちゃいけないんだと
言うと 世間ではそういう考えが立ったんですね
これはカーリ女心の信仰者やとも学者が言ってるんだからね
で カーリ神をあの信じる場合は
やっぱりこのカーリっていうのはすごい人を殺す神であって
その神の姿を自分で真似ちゃうんですね
で だからこれ乗り移ったような感じで
自分がその姿を自分でこの
なんとか真似てもなんとかするという
で 宗教であることで このヒンドゥーの人々はね
額にこちらにこの三つその線引いてるでしょ？灰で
で あれも一つこのシヴァ神のお印というかね
だからもうシヴァ神のなんか一部を姿を自分の体につけてもらって
それで宗教的な行動 行為という風にもなってしまうというかね
またいろいろことをね
そういう それはまあ何と言いますかね
専門用語あるんですけどね
で 専門用語はなかなか思い出せませんですけど
乗り移ったり 取り憑かれ
取り憑かれたりとかという俗的な言葉がありますね
で 取り憑かれたら その取り憑かれたその霊がやることは人間がやると
で その場合はちょっと次元が低い感じなんですけど
この宗教の場合はそうではなくて
あらゆる行を行って その神の姿を自分の体で表現するということなんですね
ですから カーリの神がこの首の輪というかね
首にかけているんだから
えーと まあこの人はそういう首輪をつけて
宗教儀式やったんではないかという話もある
まあとにかく人を怒りで殺したことはないんですけど
アングリマーラさんはね
で とにかく先生が言われて
そういう風にも人殺しになってしまっていると
だから彼がもうただ判断はしない
言われた通りにやるとかね
それは先生に対する尊敬とかね
まあその愛情やらね そういう感情でしょうし
神に対してだと それは神に対する愛情
感情でしょうし だからそうなっちゃうと理屈は飛んでしまうんですね
そこで彼にお釈迦様は瞬時にチリッと論理の世界を見せてくれたんですね
私は止まっている 君は
君も止まりなさいというその一言葉で
そこで彼には目で見えるのは歩いているブッダと止まっている自分と
なのに言葉でブッダが違うことを言っている
私が止まっている 君はそうではありませんと
それはどういう意味かというと
そこで説法するでしょうし
で たくさんね 生命を殺したり
武器を持ったりして それはもう薬はないと
それはもう感情で生きていることやと
あなたはどこまでそういう感情で生きているんですかと
いくらいたって感情っていうのは抑えることはないんだから
だからあなた走りっぱなしやと
私は止まっているんだよと
[咳]全ての感情と煩悩っていうのを綺麗にもう壊してるんだから
大改革心の中で起きてるんだからね
大革命ですよ で そういうことで
これは自分の心の中に革命を起こし起こしましたから
これブッダの言葉なんですけど
彼がすごく喜んで「」という
まあ楽しく歌うんですね
で 二番目 ［外国語］で
［外国語］誰かが［外国語］悪行を
［外国語］行った悪行を［外国語］善行為で［外国語］
これはちょっとまあ ［外国語］っていうのは決まってる言葉で
この［外国語］というミャンマー版の言葉もありますけど
なかなか注釈書ないんですね
これなんでしたっけ うん
注釈書には大概ないと思いますけど
これ注釈書は で まあ意味は
まあ一応注釈書ないんですから
ちょっと ［外国語］誰かが行った
まあ悪行 悪いことを［外国語］隠しておくと
だから善行為で 前と同じね
まあある意味では同じ意味でね
まあ以前は悪いことをしていても
それですぐまあ善行為で
それはもう潰してしまいなさいと
それしか方法ないんですよ
悪いことした人は だからといってどうすればいいんですかね
だったら善行為でそれをまあ潰してしまうしかないんです
で 悪いことしたんだ したんだ
どうしようもないんだということは仏教は認めません
悪いことしたならば まあ堂々と善行為で
それはまあ隠して 隠すという言葉はあまり良くないんですけど
やっぱりそれをまあ壊しておく
で あの罪がいつ滅びるかというと
やっぱりこの貪瞋痴をなくしちゃうと
もうそれで罪が全部滅びて隠れてもう壊れてしまうんですよ
貪瞋痴ある限りは 感情ある限り
我々はとんでもない間違いを起こして生きてるんですね
判断一切全体間違っているし
だから行動は決まり切って間違ってる
行動で だからこの間違ってる行動と決まり判断で
私は悪いことを償いましたとかね
こういう風に償います
いたってもそれは償ったことになりません
普通の人々は何か悪いことをして
じゃあではいいことをして
それはお釈迦様がおっしゃってるんではないかと
それはもう何とかして償い償えばいいんではないかとか
ではこういう風に償います
言ったっても その判断どうやってするんですかね
それも貪瞋痴の判断でしょ
だから 俗世間の立場では罪を犯して
私はそれはそれなりにまあ償いをしましたとか言っても
償いにはなりません どうせ自然的に出てくる結果を得られ
得なくちゃいけないんです
悪いことしたといいことをすると
悪いことの結果も出てくるし
良いことをしたことの結果も出てくる
もう消えるわけじゃないんです
悪いことしたならば 悪い結果が出てくる
それでその人は悪いことしちゃったぞと思って
ずっといいことをしちゃうと
結果として悪いことの結果も出てきて
いいことの結果も出てくる
それでたくさんいいことをしたならば
たくさんいい結果が出てくる
そこら辺で悪い結果も
まあちょっとちょっと出てくるとはあんまり気にしなくてもいいっていうぐらいのことになるだけのことで
消えるわけじゃないんです
で 消えるためには やっぱり貪瞋痴のこの感情を壊さないと
で それでこの観察するという仕事によって
物事をありのままに観察する
そういう仕事をすると
判断しないで この心の中に革命を起こしちゃうんですね
革命を起こしてしまえば
もう二度と貪瞋痴が出てこないんですね
で それでもうそれからはもう業にはもう働く場所がなくなっちゃうんですね
それで初めて悪が消えたことになります
ですから クスレーナピティーヤティというのは
ただいいことをしてごまかすという意味ではなくて
悟り開いて預流道 預流果ぐらいにでもなることなんです
預流果になったらもうかなりもうほとんどもう潰されてるんですね
業のエネルギーはね 種なんですけど
種が芽が出るでしょ それが壊れてるんですね
まだまだ種いっぱいあるかもしれませんだけど
芽は出ません だからクスレーナピティーヤティという言葉は悟ることなんですね
ただ善行為で隠すという意味ではないんですね
ですから どんな生命でもやっていることは悪行なんですよ
もうそんなややこしいことを言わなくても
まあ段々にも悪行ですよ
それで誰かがその生き方を変えて観察するようになってしまえば
もう壊れてしまうんですね
悪業世界は そういう人こそ世の中を照らすと
次 ヨーハヴェーダハロービクユンジャティブッダサーサネーソーイマンローカンパバーセティアッバハムットーアチャンディマー
ヨーハヴェーダハロービク
ダハロービク 子供のビクでも
ハヴェーっていうのは子供でもということで強調するんですね
ユンジャティブッダサーサネー
ブッダサーサネー ブッダの教えということで
一応仏教は宗教というよりはお釈迦様はブッダサーサナというんですね
宗教はパーリ語になってくるとサーサナなんですね
サーサナというのは教えという意味でありますし
実践方法という意味でも両方入ってるんですね
誰かがたとえ若い人であろうと
若い比丘であろうとも
誰でもほとんど子供ということになりますけどね
まあ若くて子供の比丘であろうとも
ユンジャティブッダサーサネー
ブッダサーサネーにおいてもう頑張って活動する
働いている ブッダサーサナというのはブッダの教えですから
ブッダの教えがこの観察
客観的に見ることだから
客観的に見ると 子供さえもこの境地に入られるんですね
この内面的な大革命を起こしちゃうんですよ
だからすごい当たり前のことで
子供でも貪瞋痴で物事を判断していて
そこそんなことじゃなくて
こういう風にしてみたらどうですかと言っちゃうと
その世界の中で貪瞋痴が消えてしまうんですよ
それでもう終わり だから仏教には子供か大人っていうとあんまり関係ないんですね
子供でも大人でも同じ貪瞋痴だから
子供には無理だとか思っていたっても
大人には無理ですけど
そんなに子供に無理ということでもないんですね
ですから そこは仏教ってすごい強調するので
真理ですから 薬は誰が飲んでも病気治るでしょうし
で そんな感じで この事実ですから
真理ですから もう誰が知ったっても同じことで
子供にしたっても 地球は丸いことは丸いでしょうし
子供だからあなたには四角いですよと
で 三十歳の人には丸いですよと
八十歳の人にはまだ平らですよという風にならないでしょうに
年によって真理変わるわけじゃないんだからね
ですから 物事を判断しないで客観的に見るこの技をね
子供に教えてあげれば
子供はそれを実行するともう悟りは開けます
ですから こちらで言っているのは
世の中を照らす人は誰ですかと
照らすと こういう人々なんですよ
たとえ以前怠っていたっても
たちまち怠ることをやめちゃって
ちゃんとこの放逸でもう観察することすると
もうその人を照らすと
もう悪いことしていても
もうたちまちそんなことはもう全部やめてしまって
もう正しく感情を壊すということに頑張ると
あるいは子供でも そのブッダのこの教えを実行すれば
そういう人々が世の中を照らしてるんだよと
それからの偈はアンリマル長老の作品なんですね
ディサーヒメダンマカタンスナントゥディサーヒメユンジャトゥブッダサーサネディサーヒメテマヌッセースーバジャントゥイエダンメーヴァーディパヤンティダンと
いろいろ問題がありますね
この英語のテキストを翻訳する人々はこの偈のメーターということを覚えてわかってないんだから
もうマヌッセーと書いてますけど
これはもうミャンマー版やらスリランカ版やら
それマヌジャという風になっていますよ
マヌジャの方は偈として正しいと思いますけどね
ディサーヒメーテマヌジャバジャントゥイエダンマンイエダンマメーヴァーディパヤンティサントイエダンマメーヴァーディパヤンティサント
その方があれメーターが守れますけど
ではディサーヒメダンマカタンスナントゥ
メーディサーヒ 私の敵で敵でも私の何でしたっけ
私の敵は忍耐を 不害を
なんとかなんとか ディサーヒメ
私の敵たちよ 私に怒っているね
私のことをあまり好きだと思ってない人々っていうことなんですね
ダンマカタンスナントゥ法を聞きなさいよと
真理を聞きなさいよと
だからアンリマル尊者がこの自分のことを怒っている人々に対しても全く怒ってないんですね
で これがもう道じゃないんだと
アンリマル尊者に殺された人々はどうせものすごく怒ってるんですけどね
自分がやったことも間違ってるし
だからといって被害者のその人々を怒っていることも
それも間違っちゃいますよと
あなた方 その意図によって不幸になるんだよと
私はもう一応もう改革をして
もうすごい喜びを感じているんだと
だからあなた方も本当にこの真理を知って幸福になってほしいと
それしかアンリマル尊者には言う言葉がないんですよ
もしアンリマル尊者が人を怒ってる人々がブッダの教えを聞いたならば
偉大なる幸福になるんだから
それ以上の何も価値がないしね
究極な価値のある真理をこの自己をもう破ってしまって
もうこの内心的にね もうこの改革を起こして
革命革命を起こして もうそれから何にも問題ない
直々なこの幸福な生き方ができるんだから
だからものこのありがたいこの教えをもう敵たちに教えてあげたいんですよ
だからすっごいこの慈しみで溢れてるんですね
アンリマル尊者は それはアンリマル尊者だけでもなくて
これ仏教の期待もあるし
敵であろうとも教えを聞いてみてよと
私の仲間になってくれという意味じゃないんですよ
敵はまあそれでも勝手に敵でいいんだけど
でもあんた方はそれで苦しんでるんだと
ですから この敵同士で戦ったりするんじゃなくて
もう自分に対して自分の国を攻めてくる敵たちがいるんだったら
敵国がいるんだったら
もうあなた方を潰してやるぞ
あなた方は悪いんだぞとかね
ということじゃなくて
もう法を聞きなさいと
ディサーヒメーユンジャトブッダサーセーネ
私の敵たちもブッダの教えを実践してみなさいよ
ディサーヒメーテーマヌジャバジャントゥ
ダンメーワアーダパヤンティサントゥ
私の敵である人々もバジャントゥダンマ
法をもう味わってみてくださいと
アーディパヤンティサントゥ
うんと うん サンタンアーディパヤンティ
サンタンというのは平安な心ですね
アーディパヤンティっていうのは
その心に導いてくれる
その心を作ってくれる
敵たちにも平安が訪れるんだと
敵たちにも幸福が得られるんだと
ですから 敵たちも私に対して怒っている敵だと思っている人々がいるならば
そういう人々もこの法を聞きなさいと
ディサーヒメーカンティワーダーナンアヴィローダッパサンシーナン
スナンツダマンカーレーナタンチャアヌヴィディーヤントゥ
ディサーヒメー 私の敵たちもカンティワーディーナン
この忍耐 あの平安ですね
カンティと言ってもクシャマだからね
忍耐を教える アヴィローダッパサンシーナン
アヴィローダっていうのは怒りのことを敵対することなんですね
でしょうかね アヴィローダ
こちら不害と書いてます
アヴィローダっていうのは
やっぱりこの敵対 敵対して立ち上がること
喧嘩すること 逆らうことなんですね
ヴィローダっていうのは
だから 誰かに対して逆らって敵として立ち上がらないことをアヴィローダなんですね
不害ですね  いわゆる誰かに対して害を与えないという
カンティワーディーナンというのは
この忍耐を解くものというのはブッダですね
ブッダが忍耐というものは忍耐と言ったっても
この平安なんですよ みんなで平和で仲良くという意味で忍耐と書きますが
パーリ語だったらクシャーティティっていうのはもう腹が立たないことなんですよ
いわゆる攻撃しないこと
攻撃されても攻撃しないことはクシャーティなんです
パーリ語の意味は 日本語の意味は忍耐にはなっています
で これはクシャーティという言葉は漢文で忍耐という言葉で訳するんだから
そうなっていると思います
どちらが正しいかと私はわかりません
一応パーリ語の意味はもう殴っても殴り返しません
攻撃しても攻撃しません
というと 忍耐ではないかと
ずっと我慢して というふうにも理屈つけられますけど
まあどういう意味でしょうかね
やっぱり やっぱり平安で穏やかでいることなんですよ
ただ攻撃してもじっと耐えているということでもないんです
じっと耐えているとやっぱり苦しいんだからね
シャーンティというのは心の状態なんですよ
攻撃したっても別に気にしない
心を穏やかで平安で保つということ
攻撃されても怒らないよと
だから怒りが生まれてくると
この怒りを抑えて殺して平安な心を作る
それはシャーンティ アヴィルッダ・パサンセーナ
アヴィローダ・パサンセーナ
アヴィローダっていうのはヴィローダという
ヴィローダっていうのはもう私は反対だというふうに反対行動を取ることですね
ですから攻撃することで
それはしないこと もう攻撃するなよと
誰にも その人 それはブッダのことなんです
その人のダンマンスナと法を聞きなさいよ
カーレーナ まあ時期ということですね
アヌ・ヴィディーヤント
時期に応じて聞くが良いと書いてます
それに従い行くが良い
時に応じて聞く  時に応じて
カーレーナというのはなかなかね
大変な意味は難しいんですけど
こちらはまあ 時に応じて
どんな時に応じてかということでもになりますしね
法を聞く時っていうのはないんですよ
もう 1 日も早く聞くべきなんですよ
だから仏教では時に応じてっていうのは今すぐ聞いて今すぐ悟りなさいということなんです
1時間でも延ばすなよと
延ばしちゃうとどうなるかわからないんだと
で 本当の時に応じてっていうのはその意味なんです
で 全て無常で いつ人が死ぬかわからないし
明日どうなるかわからないし
だから明日に延ばすなよということは
仏教の時に応じることなんですね
ですから 時に応じてダンマを聞いて実践しなさいと
本当のところ 早くも聞きなさいという意味なんですね
1 日でも延ばしちゃうと
その 1 日はものすごい苦しんで生活することになる
その 1 日以内でもう取り返せない何か悪いことをする可能性もある
あるいは死ぬかもしれません
あるいはブッダが亡くなるかもしれません
インドではお釈迦様もあちこちお歩きになったんだから
もう何日一箇所にいるかわからないんですよ
そこで人々はブッダがお釈迦様がいらっしゃいましたと聞いたら
全て仕事 作業 何だかんだ全部やめて
もう法を聞いて もうさっさと実践しようとする
でないと また今度来たら来ない
来ないかもしれません
お釈迦様 時間 スケジュールで動くのではないんだから
そういうことです ですから
この 時に応じてということは
やっぱりすぐ聞きなさいということなんですね
人は年を取るとともに
法にふさわしい法を実践できなくなるようになっちゃうんですよ
すごいこの精神的な力が
もう感情をどんどん強くなっていくんですよ
だから感情に屁理屈つける習慣が増えれば増えるほど強くなるでしょ
だから子供の方が早いんですよ
屁理屈少ないんだから
我々は年取れば取るほど
自分の感情にどんどんどんどんどんどん理屈つけてるんですよ
勉強すればするほど そういう屁理屈つけっぱなしで
それと同時に体も弱くなっていると
どうせ知識よりは感情の方が高くなり
強くなってくる エネルギーのバランスで
だから早くてもやった方がいいと
仏教が始めた時はもうかなり若者の間で人気だったんですよ
大勢の若者 若いとみんなお釈迦様が若かったし
もう弟子たちももうほとんどもう若かったし
このヤサという人がね
ものすごい若者で もう出家して
それでいきなり 60人になっちゃったんですね
彼の 55人の友達がもう
みんなさっと出家したらもう六十人もみんな若者
お釈迦さんでした お釈迦様も同じ
もう大した年の差がない
六十一人も みんな完璧に悟って
それからももうかなり若者の間では人気だったんですけどね
ですから この早くともという意味で取るんですよ
カーレーナっていうのは
まあそのうちという意味じゃないんです
暇ができたらって意味じゃないんです
暇が出ないはずなん どんどん暇がなくなるんだからね
はい 次の偈に行きます
ナヒ ジャートゥ ソー ママン ヒンセー アンニャン ワーパナ カンチナン パップイヤ パラマン サンティン ラックヘイヤ タサ ターヴァレ
それはすごい簡単な意味ですから
日本語でいきます どういう意味ですか？私を決して害さないですか
他をも何をも害せない
彼は無上の寂静を得て
動不動のものを守る 難しいね
ネヒ ジャートゥ ソー ママン ヒンセー
ジャートゥ 生命はネヒ ママン ヒンセー
私に害を与えないでください
私に邪魔をしないでくださいということなんですね
人々よ 私に迷惑かけないでください
アンニャン ワーパナ カンチナン
人々よ 他の生命にも迷惑かけないでくれ
いわゆるまとめて言えば
人は人に迷惑かけないでくれという慈悲の瞑想なんですね
人が私にも害を与えないように
誰も私にも害を与えない
私も誰にも害を与えないようにと
互いにも互いに互いに誰も害を与えないようにと
そのようにしてパップイヤ パラマン サンティン
もうパラマン 最高なこの平安になってください
パップイヤっていうのはその状態に至ってくださいと
シャンティっていうのは寂静でもよろしいし
平安な心ですね 自分に誰も自分に誰か害を与える
自分が平安がないんですよ
害を受けて欲しくないんだから
受けたくないんだから
ですから 私に害を与えないでくださいと
そうすると私は平安だよと
あなた方も互いに害を与えないでくださいと
そういうふうにみんな平安で平和であってほしいと
全ての生命 パラマンサンティンとは互いに害を与えなきゃそれだけで世界は平和なんですね
それで心がすごく安らぎを感じるんですね
それから次にラッケイヤタサターワレ
タサターワラっていうのは生命のこと
もうタサっていうのはもう安定している生命
動かない生命 イジャ 動く生命
怯えている生命 ちょっちゃしたことで混乱したり怯えたりする
まあ精神的な弱い生命かもしれません
ターワラっていうのはものすごく安定している生命なんですね
だからみんなを守りましょうと
で 世の中の考え方は まあ弱い者を守りましょうと
そういう者は守ってあげないという場合もある
あるいは逆に もう金持ちの人やら金ある豊かな人だけを応援して
もう貧しい人々はもうあっち行けと追い出すとかね
あの人を応援して守ってあげれば
私にも何か利益があるんじゃないかというふうな生き方をしている
こんな貧しい人の目に見たらもう面倒くさいと
自分持っているものなくなるんだから出ていけというふうにも言う人々もいるし
あるいは逆に もう貧しい人だったら
もう難民だったら助けてあげますけど
他の人々に爆弾を仕掛けろとという人々もいる
そういうことではなくて
人間というのは幸福であろうが
豊かであろうが 安定していようが不安定であろうが
みんなを守りましょうと
生命だから まあそこら辺でやめます
[終始背景音楽]